a mis la vie si tous kankan est
astucieux peine
faites suer le plus sérieux est à jouer
il suffit de vouloir revenir à un ami
et au volatil parce que tu veux faire
des parties bonjour bonjour chad reed
bonjour bonjour tout encore salah est ce
que tu connais la grimace du serpent a
refait mal croque talent tu veux je te
fasse de grattage un regard de grand
talent ça fait peur
je n'ose pas sortir ta langue comme ça
tu veux que je te fasse l'amande douce
on nous ça ça me fait trop peur on adore
la mangue ou je t'en supplie alors le
jeu alors le jeu géographique
gj vais moi dans ce pays ah bon mais
maintenant bon alors le désir la rose
trémière ah bon je suis aujourd'hui
c'est comme ça d'accord les fleurs moi
je les ai un vote à chaque fois raison
carte géographique du pays en question
voilà la carte de ce pays qu'il faut
deviner à vous remarquerez une chose
importante il n'y a pas de côtes dans ce
pays qui est entouré par tous deux
voisins il n'y a pas de mer autour de la
capitale est ici un pays sans mère là
c'est un pays sans merveilles en fait là
bas si tu veut en quelque sorte oui
voici le drapeau du pays je précise les
couleurs la bande supérieure et rouge
ici là vous avez le blanc est là le vert
gouez blanc vallis c'est horizontale
ce sont des bandes horizontales et dire
ça a pris pour ça se voit elle voit
alors on a un bon jour dans la langue du
pays
ah bah oui la prononciation je n'en suis
pas très sûr mais je crois que c'est
liona pote yonhap hot yonhap bonjour
bonjour c'est une homme très difficile
aussi extrêmement difficile vous avez
devinez de quel pays il s'agit regardez
bien
c'est là tôt ap tom wilson quoi je
voudrais lui trouver dit le alors que
c'est un jeu c'est pouces moussu ce
qu'il a fait aujourd'hui avant celui qui
l'a fait aujourd'hui à allah dit il m'a
dit que c'était la hongrie c'est vrai
c'est ce qui m'a dit non la nuit tous
les chats sont gris
oui qu'a fini oui tu veux ça j'ai un
petit peu la capitale et budapest qui se
trouve ici
budapest voilà c'était langue début
d'année festive d'un côté but d'à de
l'autre pêche mais marchand la ville et
réunissait
après ces bases doivent être l'autre
côté va j'y vais immédiatement dans le
jardin ya pas de problème c'est si c'est
sûr et pis toi oui il arrive donc à
passer outre la valeur fait le point
commun c'est bien commun non mais je
l'appelle fabre et paris bah oui oui oui
alors là ça peut être difficile parce
qu'aujourd'hui chez en pleine forme
aa je suis sûr de voir ça alors oui je
commence rivasi bon alors aujourd'hui -
fabrice je suis une toute petite partie
d'un accessoires d'habillement attention
écoute jeudi accessoires 1
je ne suis pas avec moi je suis un
accessoire très liés à certains
vêtements en général pour les faire
tenir les délais
c'est le cas des pantalons aux hommes
mais les femmes qui lisent aussi pour
rien comme ça pour faire chic elle me
met autour de leur taille ils me
prennent en cuir en toile en métal
prennent le large du cuir de la toile
etc
alors je pense que tu a reconnu
l'accessoire dont je veux parler et moi
je suis je te le répète une toute petite
partie de cet accessoire mais alors
vraiment tout petit
oui bah c'est petit c'est pas évident
moi ce sera peut-être évident alors moi
la chose oui imari d'agrémenter ma
coiffure grâce à ce comment est ce que
je pourrai dire à ces petites choses que
je suis aujourd'hui
car en ce moment je porte un chapeau oui
je lis d'ailleurs alors vous ne pouvez
pas vous en rendre compte
mais lorsque je sors nu tête cela
m'arrive parfois que je veux garder une
certaine élégance
je n'aime pas avoir les cheveux raides
je n'aime pas non plus les chignons
alors je les arrange ou je les fais
arrangé par mon coiffeur je lui demande
de me faire quelques chèques non non non
non je ne peux pas peu dire le mot
puisque c'est justement celui que qui
datent de vie
a lhassa va un peu mieux pouces moussu
et bien moi moi je crois je crois mon
cher fabrice que je vais vous étonner
oui d'abord je dois vous prévenir ce que
je suis aujourd'hui ce n'est pas un
objet mais c'est quelque chose de très
très apprécié ceux qui en possèdent
on les admire ça prouve qu'ils sont
courageux qui n'ont pas peur de se
lancer dans des entreprises difficile et
même quelquefois dangereuse car par
exemple tu décides de faire une
promenade à bicyclette
tu t'en vas tu tombes tu te fais mal tu
te blesses à un genou et est battue
continue quand même tu vas jusqu'au bout
bah ça ça prouve que tu as dû en fin du
fin de ce que je suis aujourd'hui voilà
un oui oui oui ça y est aie aie ça y est
oui et vous aussi ça y est vous avez
trouvé de quoi il s'agit
souvenez vous ce que nous a dit tout à
l'heure tous cancan ne serais-tu point
un cran tout con quand je suis un cran
je m'en suis toujours douté et bien
c'est un cran alors qu'il s'agissait
pour elles d'un maquereau de coiffure
10.1 moment audi lit dans les chiffres
et je suis à grant oiseaux
oui en 3o quant à pouss moussu et oui il
s'agit du cran avoir du cran et
quelqu'un de très courageux où il a du
cran excellent dessin elle est bien
cette coque pas à marcher à fabrice
havre havre a beaucoup d'eau
vous vous de bonn pardo a voulu relier
pas de glace salade nord prend
maintenant c'est pas le moment rapporté
au studio icp personne faisait pas ça
oui mon cas nous sommes occupés
nous travaillons et bien je vous laisse
là avant bell bundy c'est pourquoi je
m'en vais bien célébrer le jeu musical
exactement quant à bruxelles jusqu'au 20
pouces coûte rien ça va être à nouveau
fabrice giletta suivent à givet tableau
battant je regarde d'abord si je n'ai
pas oublié mon stylo cela oui bravo pour
notre jeu c'est très important
tu vois nous sommes parés à l'evo n'ya
pas de courant à dire par ici massue ça
arrive parfois avery a alors cette
semaine
ça va se passer cette semaine tu te sens
bien fabrice ça va pas on va voir ça bon
alors je vais essayer de thé taux n'est
pas par des fautes d'orthographe
j'écoute je vais travailler toute la
semaine alors on vient d'être bon alors
c'est un mot ans est les truies première
alors la première c'est un ssl 2 3
combien de lettres matudi acheté dix ans
cette lettre dont l'ue fait cinq petits
couacs 4,5 dernière lettre
la dernière lettre avec toi c'est pas la
peine de se fatiguer obsédé par les
animaux c'est un animal ben oui bah oui
bien sûr elle ment c'est un animal bon
hein un gros oui enfin oui oui les
moyens qui courent ah non ils courent
pas folle ivo louis danoise au golf
c'est un oiseau un oiseau de nos régions
oh oui oh oui on en trouve dans nos
régions surtout dans l'est en afrique
offre cependant elle traverse l'afrique
bacchus et avance un oiseau migrateur
exactement un oiseau migrateur
et oui avec la nes veux tu veux tu que
je te donne une lettre supplémentaire
pour t d un peu oui parce que il y en a
beaucoup d'oiseaux mais alors la
troisième lettre c'est un jouet un jeu
voilà c'est un jeu wii 1 g l oiseau
migrateur 1
mais dis donc tu ne t'es pas trompé la
cua un oiseau migrateur à l'oiseau
migrateur qui a dans les régions de
l'est de la france mais qui vendent à
lorient c'est avec un g ici ça pourrait
être une cigogne et bat exactement à
trouver pour voir comment tu écris
cigognes tout cas encore à toi de
réponse toews avait il écrit j'écris ce
que vous êtes toujours raison
à la barre oui j'ai des problèmes et
bien chez chris igwe sign&go gigogne
c'est à cette annonce vous souhaite un
bon voilà comment on écrit cigognes sont
capables j'ai encore fait une faute
d'orthographe rit on pour un malheureux
qui sait à la place quand même s'est dit
inquiet barry j
11 g n le et qu'il monde le sait ça tous
nos amis savent comme on écrit ça ici le
bien mais je ne savais pas trop au
sérieux là ou là vous avez vu ce que tu
ne savais pas non plus tôt une cigogne
au dessus du talent et pourtant et
pourtant et pourtant reconnaît j'en
connais des choses sur les cigognes oui
je sais que pour retrouver la chaleur en
hiver bas elles font des voyages de dix
à douze mille kilomètres
je sais qu'elles sont toujours été très
aimé des hommes et qu'elles elles le
savent bien parce que c'est même pour ça
qu'on peut les approcher assez
facilement
elles n'ont pas peur des hommes à moi je
peux te dire tu vas tu vois que je sais
quand même beaucoup de choses sur les
cigognes triel vont l'hiver en afrique
oui il faut décrire of notamment on voit
des knicks et c'est pour ça qu'on les
appelle des oiseaux bravo pouces moussu
et bah oui toujours quand tu t'es pas
beaucoup fatigué qu'on va vivre dans son
ensemble parce que jésus a dit
aujourd'hui si nous allons dans cete
avec bébé
[Musique]
là tu n'as pas bouffer ce que j'ai fait
ici la musique tu verras que toi tu es
en 2007
cela devrait amener ça me fascine tant
de 10 tonnes
oui c'est pas compliqué c'est un mot des
histoires que j'étais raconte également
nos dates de musique oui oui oui oui oui
et toutes ces notes de nouveau le début
de la chanson dont je vais je racontais
l'histoire à aujourd'hui
oui c'est l'histoire d'une jeune fille
qui se promène dans une très jolie jo de
france
rey jean genet en bas ou en rollers et
et bien à temps que je réfléchisse mais
les dons en bas en ba oui et alors c'est
une fille lettres sable paco que du tout
eu seul n'est pas comme on dit qui à
quatre épingles tir et oui encore un ré
embauche bah oui oui d'ailleurs elle a
bien raison de ne pas interrompre la
sema qui viennent est en feu tout de
même je parle à fabrice enfin oui alors
elle n'a pas besoin de se maquiller
parce que elle possède naturellement
bons coups d éclat d'éclat et bien tu es
à trouver mais au cours de sa promenade
elle rencontre des gens qui se moquent
d'elle ce sont du genre à lui veut dire
mabri des mâles après oui heureusement
salle est bien égal ce qu'ils peuvent
dire d'elles elles n'ont fait pas une
marque ville une quoi il m'a dit seconde
mi-temps bull tout va bien je cherche
qu'une lune une maladie c'est qu'elle
elle s'est tue challenge lycée du roi
mais enfin ne chatouille pas fabrice
durand sipa le fils le roi est amoureux
d'elle et lui coupant l'eau froide et
bouquets de marjolaine ou de litres
de quoi des bouquets de marjolaine mais
non puisque c'est une note de musique
cas de lido de lido non de lire et de
limites de l'ifan lysol de lits de lille
à deux galas de la ville de remettre
plein de ton attention violi la wii mais
je te remets replonge de tant
d'attentions tu as compris je te
remercie de l'attention herbe
je ne fera pas de mal à trouver la
preuve lucien ouimet solution d'exercer
la ré lalalala s'esquisse achats en
passant par la lorraine mettre mon
prénom non attends là la dépêche tout a
basculé l'on me morel monde du 8 mai à
meaux tu ta dignité les pilotes de la
vilaine d'allaoui sa gorge trouvait là a
tout de suite bien à tout de suite pas
chez moi on va chanter
l'état n'est déjà pas permis que la vie
me désiste et rzeszow fait des choses
mais comme jenny pas de miroir livre on
a peur
ensemble les quatre amis se contentera t
sont réunis les quatre ça me semble
heureux car il aime à mai
oui
aujourd'hui vouloir devenir un ami
[Musique]
nous nous amusons